it's easy to complain that our maps of
Mars and Venus are way more detailed
than our maps of our own Earth's ocean
but listen Mars and Venus don't have a
bunch of water getting in the way of
mapping them we can just throw
satellites up there and take pictures to
map the ocean floor to a resolution of
at least 100 meters we need ships
equipped with sonar which create maps by
beaming out sound waves at the ocean
floor and measuring how long it takes
for them to get back we'd only need
about 200 of these ships to map the
whole damn ocean it would take like a
year though I'll admit running these
ships for a year with a bunch of
personnel on board ain't she good news
is that someone is working on this
Nippon foundation and gebco got together
to start the seabed 2030 with the goal
of getting a detailed map of our oceans
by 2030. they're also investing in
faster and cheaper methods like these
little cute submarine robots that take
unmanned Expeditions into the ocean to
create even higher resolution Maps this
is like a leap forward that will allow
future generations to explore more of
Earth's surface than all other
Generations combined